Brian how are you this morning oh man
how are you I'm great let me start with
the extra points here were you on the
extra point team with the Bears yes I
was my whole career the philosophy of
extra points back then to what it is now
why is it changed so dramatically I
think well obviously it's harder now
they moved it back a little bit so the
ball comes out a little bit lower I
would think but we still tried to block
it back in the day you know we are
coached always putting we working on
every single day for extra point block
and p80 whatever we always had a five
minute set aside for special teams to do
that before practice we didn't just
stand there and I stood there because I
had a guy in coverage they ran a fake
but we we still try to block it but now
it's just and the kickers are missing
them they're blocking their it's all
kinds of stuff going on now what do you
think in the extra point move back 15
years it makes it more interesting I
think it's fun you see more teams go 4-2
now which it which makes the game
interesting for me as well I don't
necessarily like it but it's a little
bit different than normal did you watch
the packers last night against the
redskins yeah i did a solo game i
watched all day i was traveling all day
so I caught the second half of that game
does aaron rodgers look any different to
you just i mean i think i asked them do
a whole bunch of stuff there are some
throws that you're gonna only see and
make you know we just wouldn't spoil
them because he never makes a mistake
everything you see he throws the guy
makes an unbelievable play to make it
either it's tipped or the guy has to
dive to catch it and now you know it's a
little different this year because he is
under quite he's under more pressure me
that they can't run the football either
drop in seven eight guys so there's a
little different but still if you put
his numbers for the Bears quarterback
the Bears would be happy as hell Tigers
aren't and Aaron's not but if you put
those numbers for the Bears quarterback
they would be on they would be ecstatic
where are the Bears is a franchise right
now that's a good question that I don't
know you know I think they're going I'm
a huge fan of cold spots as a human face
will get things changes they give them a
chance um the day out there almost back
to rebuild
figs now I think a quarterback they're
gonna havta for the talk around Chicago
is either start over again next year and
I start over but oj won't be there so
that's fine new quarterback I fake
lawyer could be a nice bridge for them
for a while he he's done a good job will
he was in there would you rather face a
great offensive line or a great
quarterback um i would say great
offensive line as a quarterback you know
they can change the calls they can get
rid of all fast and make drop until I
look really good what would you rather
face the Cowboys offensive line or dak
Prescott neither they are there good as
you know I grew up a Cowboys fan so it's
kind of fun for me to watch right now
this is just like the old days man they
used to just pound the ball the actual
my flight control was but I mean to
watch these young kids get out there and
do what they've been doing and their
defense is playing solid you know
they're not great by any means but they
get the job done broadmeadows got those
guys flying at a football they don't get
a lot of sex but they make enough plays
to win games would you think a real nose
speech during the week I didn't see it i
was watching i was on the treadmill I
saw part of it i didn't i didn't hear it
though um you know I you know like a man
you know how much you can do I don't
know how you can expect to do that he
doesn't spec to be put back in there are
teams on a nine game win streak I just
it stinks you know take a minute played
great and no one expected it but then
there's talk about maybe the Bears add
him or I mean there's there feels like
you know cuz ya from Eastern Illinois so
i don't know if that's going to be a
landing spot he's going to have some
options there but i just don't know if
you go all in on Tony Romo if you're the
chicago bears here we thought I'm on an
ESPN show up well and silly Sarah
Chicago ever llegan they talked about
that I was shocked you know it another
biggest funny but i think is going to be
37 38 this year he's been banged up the
last three or four years the bears
offensive line isn't that great you know
if he can stay healthy behind that line
in Dallas and they have a hard time in
Chicago as well just I was surprised to
hear that i think you know if they're
going to move on from jail you got to
get a little bit younger yeah that's if
you're going to sort of start over I can
use Hoyer there and not go all in an
investment
one draft Baker's spend a lot of money
so here you're gonna have to do have to
pay the salary which is quite a bit yeah
unless they cut him obviously you got to
trade for him so there's a lot going on
there if you figure I'm trying to make
that move he said Brian Urlacher the
linebacker former linebacker for the
Bears joining us have you ever been in
that position where Luke keatley was the
other night what happened to him I
didn't see much of the game I saw him
look so at first when I saw the replay I
thought he broke his leg or something
because the way is the face he was
making me job offer to feel like he look
like he was upset so I thought maybe he
blew his Achilles there's me or some
what happened to him well he suffered a
concussion they said but if you look at
the video i thought is he messed up his
knee and then i thought he got the wind
knocked out of him and then they said he
was in concussion protocol and I didn't
know if that's how players sometimes
react when they suffered concussion I
mean he was very emotional so I don't
know it yeah if you ever felt that way
thought especially where i thought i
thought he and I season was over because
the way he reacted i was able to watch
this play because i don't like watching
the place where guys get hurt it sickens
me so I just put my hand up over the TV
but I saw him driving off of it all and
spur guys that must have a really bad
injury but then they're like halogen
concussion protocol so first thing I've
never had that kind of reaction i only
had one major concussion and it wasn't i
didn't act like that I got to stay on
the field so it was a little different
scenario for me to have been Luclin
developers okay I'm sure he will be
eventually but um that was the first
time I to someone react like that wait
wait wait you've had one major Kenny
minor concussions did you have I had a
few you know well back in the day didn't
matter you know you could concussed the
major one I had a miss two plays and
went back in you know it was so
different back then and I might have had
it you know during games you might get
dinged up a little bit nothing just a
little woozy after good here but you
mean nothin where you need to come out
of game is like Wells a really good hit
and you keep playing but ours is it
because they tackle differently now I
don't know what I mean I think it's more
prevalent now and people are looking for
you know back in the day they weren't
really looking for concussions now they
got someone assigned to every game they
look for concussions if I there's a big
hit those guys have to leave the game to
make sure they
concussed you know so it's just
different now the way they look at the
the show is on Golf Channel it's wilson
golf reality TV show it's driver versus
driver tomorrow night will be the finale
at 10 Eastern on the golf channel so
you're you're on the panel they're sort
of like shark tank where you're going to
decide who wins this yeah I'm not for
judging on Phase II began I know so much
about golf how to make it's been a
really fun show man so Tim Clark the
director or the president wilson golf is
a guy I met through Kevin's German a few
years ago and asked me be a part of the
show and I jumped us like a I do it you
know basically people submit their
drivers nope it's awesome it's open
competition anyone and they submit their
drivers to uh to the panel and we go
through all these submissions and we
pick the one driver that we think is the
best i love them and then they make have
some figured hathon mein dollars if they
went and it will seem to market their
driver and sell it i do find it
interesting sometimes when you play with
football players like Eddie George when
I played with him he's so much bigger
than me and so much stronger and he
thought because of that he had hit it
further than Harvard and any keti was
hit it like 220 yards and it was
emasculating him did you ever play with
teammates who you know big guys who felt
like they were going to be able to crush
it well I'm pretty big you know I feel
like I should have further you know I
think the golf is so different in that
aspect cuz you play those smaller guys
and they have the their hips are perfect
timing is perfect and they crushed by
you Michael you know I should really
gonna buy you buy golf work she gotta
have your swing on playing at every
timing right it's a little different
than most sports who humbles you though
thank you playing again you play against
pros yeah I play with a lot of pros now
say with bubba watson i play with
Ricky's my favorite retailers 5857 maybe
140 pounds and his two was fitted 60
yards five much kevin chappell and kevin
streelman a good friends of mine as well
and they uh they just piss off my boss
is like air ball flies my ball by 30
yards in the air and i'll hit a good
woman be like oh good that one okay bond
right over me the season finale of
driver versus driver on the golf channel
that will be tomorrow night at ten
eastern tune in to
see how Brian Urlacher's hair looks how
is the hair Oh Dan it's it's good i need
to get a cut right now it's uh built at
some time on did i get ready time now i
gotta wake up the morning comelec then
woke up a minute ago i'm going to the
gym but i had to brush my hair first we
saw there was a little like a freak to
gym but it's looking good man um okay
complain too much about it can you can
you could you get a mullet could you
part it down the middle I could I could
do whatever I wanted that's how much air
I can grow now I can do whatever I want
to with my yeah but you were you
wouldn't be as intimidating if you
played known you had hair though Brian
ya know for sure you know it was
different back then back when I play I
didn't want here when I played because
first of all I'll be the dad on five or
ten minutes to might get ready times
every day two or three showers a day
when I played what's you know an extra
20 minutes a day there so it's a totally
different now it's you know that the
easy factor we've been out the window
back affected so jay cutler would shave
his head maybe he'd be a little better
with his prep time well yeah I don't
know what you know I got no comment
almost I almost got you to the line is
free roll there I would I must turn to
camden movers have fun tomorrow night
great talk to you again man all right
Victor advanced rider lunker the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience